welcome home is coming right it's not my  name young mr. Connor  I'm sprite welcome to the neighborhood  thank you I hope you'll be happy here  Sarah Julia hi Jim Galloway Big Brother  moment I spared  I'm pressed on Lily that were getting  married how well do you really know to  you she has no idea how to parent that's  the sense that she found Lily talking to  some guy what guy she seemed to think of  use on she was the man you were talking  to at the market  [Music]  I'm scared you're not getting off your  horse come on Lily I'm sorry who asked  you  we're leaving you only get one mother  Lily don't ever forget that  [Music]  where's your ring alchemy I'm aware now  who sent you flowers she's messing with  me  [Music]  David threatening me yes he is dangerous  she away from all of us  using different products it's my life  not yours  you  [Music]  you